sociation sur le futur grand barrage de
la renaissance dure depuis neuf ans
maintenant autour de la table l'ethiopie
l'egypte et le soudan
des échanges qui ont permis de régler
95% des problèmes techniques
aujourd'hui l'accord bute encore sur
l'aspect politique et juridique du
partage des eaux du nil des pourparlers
qui entre désormais dans une phase
décisive voire dangereuse addis abeba ne
veut plus attendre et envisage de
remplir le réservoir de son méga barrage
un remplissage qui pourrait se faire dès
le mois prochain début de la saison des
pluies en ethiopie et une situation qui
inquiète le caire qui menace depuis
plusieurs jours de porter le différend
devant le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies la responsabilité du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu en vertu de
la charte et de faire face aux actions
qui menace la paix et la sécurité
internationales certainement les actions
unilatérales de l'ethiopie à cet égard
constituerait une telle menace et par
conséquent le conseil de sécurité
devrait prendre les mesures appropriées
pour éviter qu'une telle situation ne se
développe
nous ne demandons aucune action
coercitive de la part du conseil de
sécurité mais seulement de réitérer une
invitation aux états à poursuivre les
négociations et à s'abstenir de toute
action unilatérale une action
unilatérale exclu en soit toute
possibilité de réengagement frais claude
mais pour l'ethiopie il est hors de
question que les nations unies
interviennent dans ce conflit régional
somme le problème du barrage peut être
résolu et si au lieu de le porter au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu nous
pensons ce n'est pas le mandat du
conseil de sécurité
ce projet est un projet de développement
le précédent que ça crée pour le monde
est très mauvais ce n'est vraiment pas
le rôle du conseil de sécurité
cela peut aussi être considérée comme
une ingérence dans les activités
pacifiques d'une nation souveraine
il n'est donc pas juste de porter cette
affaire à l'eau note
le soudan a de son côté mis en garde ce
dimanche contre une escalade des
tensions pour lever les derniers
obstacles khartoum propose d'ailleurs
une ré
rapide avec les premiers ministres
égyptiens et d'éthiopiens sans préciser
de date
en attendant une réunion en
vidéoconférence de la ligue arabe est
prévue ce mardi pour tenter de donner un
nouveau souffle aux négociations
le grand barrage de la renaissance a été
lancé par l'ethiopie en 2011 sur le nil
bleu près de la frontière avec le soudan
un projet ambitieux d'addis abeba se
chiffrant à 5 milliards de dollars pour
ériger le plus grand barrage
hydroélectrique d'afrique
un ouvrage pharaonique avec ses 145 m de
haut près de deux kilomètres de long et
ses seize turbines si l'ethiopie voit le
barrage comme essentiel à son
développement
le soudan et l'egypte craignent qu'il ne
restreignent leur accès à l'eau le nil
qui coule sur quelques 6000 km est une
source d'approvisionnement en or bleu et
en électricité est essentielle pour une
dizaine de pays d'afrique de l'est